whether you're unclear as to how all the
pieces of Netflix's new hit show lock
and key fit together you want answers to
some of its bigger questions or you're
simply hankering for some hints as to
where season to my head this is what you
need to know first things first at the
end of the day dodge Wern dodges real
goal wasn't stealing the Omega key it
was opening the black door she didn't
need the Omega key to accomplish that
she simply had to trick Tyler Kinzie and
Bodie into opening the door for her
which they do despite Kinsey's eventual
better judgment does this feel right to
you
if you have any better ideas I'm all
ears best available I do doesn't make
something a good idea Dargis scheme
isn't shown on screen kana logically so
here's roughly how it works first the
Dutch uses the identity key to transform
Elly into well dodge then she straight
up knocks or else next dodge uses a
crown of Shadows to summon an army and
leaves an attack on key house
well the stakes feel real they're nuts
dodge intends to let the kids win then
she drops Ellie's body
disguises her own where the children can
find it in order to dispose of Dodge for
good Tyler Kinzie and Bodhi need to put
it back in the well house and
fortunately no one knows where Ellie hit
the echo key so instead the kids decide
to open the black door using the Omega
key and dump a Dodge inside see where
this is going the children and their
friends throw Ellie's disguise poly
through a portal even as one of dodges
to monic peers escape dodges biggest
threats Ellie is gone her other enemies
think she's had longer part of the
equation and now she has an equally
powerful and hungry parliament crime to
help out the lux sing they won but dodge
could everything she wanted of course
getting rid of Ellie and opening the
black door it's at the only way that
dodges set herself up for success in
season 2 as a final moments of locking
keys first season reveal she's also
earned Kinzie's trust and a hut by using
the identity key to masquerade as gabe a
member of Kinzie's friend group as the
season closing montage implies dodge has
been masquerading as Gabe since the very
beginning it was dodge in the lobster
suit it will start you tortured Edirne
using the music box key it was thought
you stole Kinzie away from Scotts that
tracks Gabe doesn't appear until after
Bodie gives dodge tea anyway key in the
first episode and his pitch-perfect
emotional manipulation of Kinzie always
felt a little predatory a Dodge Gabe
deception echoes one of the graphic
novels main plot lines although it works
a little differently in the book the
identity key it doesn't exist in the
comics instead the Dodge uses a super
Street for the name to gender key to
switch between her male and female forms
masquerading as a boy named Zack the
male dodge who looks exactly like
Ellie's old boyfriend Lucas becomes
Tyler's best friend and Kinsey's
boyfriend expects something similar to
follow in season 2 still it's not like
Tyler Kinzie and Bodie ended
lock-and-key season 1 and a completely
down note well it might have been duped
into a false sense of security they did
grow immensely thanks to their
adventures in key house and are able to
get over the death
dad Rendell look when locking key begins
tyler blames himself for Rendell's
murder when Tyler's former classmate
some lesser makes a crack about offing
his father tyler jokingly asked Sam to
kill Rendell too when Sam actually does
murder Rendell Tyler can't above feel
responsible meanwhile Kinzie can't
forgive herself for being too afraid to
fight some during the attack ultimately
Brody's trauma is a lot more simple he
just misses his dad I want to see my dad
please however after some visits key
Howson reveals that he's in league with
dodge pilot realizes a Rendell's death
had nothing to do with him
Kinzie copes with her shame by literally
dragging her fear from her head and
trying to kill it she only forgives
herself once Tyler points out that she
wasn't able to stop Sam because she was
too busy protecting Bodhi the youngest
locked sibling is now connected to
Rendell's legacy through key house and
the magic keys which Randall also used
as a boy the loss of Randall will always
be a big factor in the kids lives but as
a season concludes they're also finally
able to move on your house is filled
with amazing keys there's a key that can
let you step outside your body and be a
ghost one big mystery that locking Keys
first season leaves hanging is a keys
true nature we know they're magic but
why are they in key house and where did
they come from
if locking key continues to stick to the
comic books mythology we can find the
answer there too quite simply the keys
are made out of the bodies of the
children of Lang a race of demons
straight out of H P Lovecraft's playbook
and were forged by the lochs ancestors
in order to control the forces beyond
the black door in the comics when a
child of Leng comes out of the black
tour they don't just die when they fail
to find a host they actually turn into a
substance known as whispering iron when
Benjamin Locke discovered the black dog
during the Revolutionary War he quickly
realized how dangerous it was and used
to Whispering iron to make the Omega key
keeping the door shuts engine went on to
make a number of other keys which he hid
around key house for later generations
to find again later seasons of the
Netflix show my retcon or streamline
this history a little bit but the show's
been faithful so far it doesn't seem
likely to change too much even for comic
book readers it's hard to tell exactly
where Netflix is locking key is headed
the first season burned through lots of
the comics major plot points are a
pretty rapid pace
leaving the future very
key still there are few things we know
we haven't seen all of key houses magic
keys without giving too much away keys
like the animal key that angel key the
owl key and the giant key will look
great on screen and should be lots of
fun
Duncan the kids from the uncle has very
little to do in season one but plays a
much bigger role as the story progresses
and if you think Dodgers finished with
bode just wait the little guy is in for
a very very rough time the show also
raises new questions at the comics never
dealt with Kinsey's fear is attacking
her classmates how will the kids stop it
Ellie isn't dead she's just trapped
beyond the black door it's her time on
the show done or she find her way back
through there are a lot of loose ends to
tie up
season 2 can't get here soon enough
until then Aloha
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos but
your favorite stuff are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and to
the pal so you don't miss a single one
[Music]